ich persönlich finde dass die ersten
drei Fastentage die schwersten sind an
mein Nachttisch kommt immer Wasser
Schwarzkümmelöl und entkernte Datteln am
nächsten Morgen war ich dafür dass der
erste Tag war echt extrem fit und ich
habe die ganze Wohnung noch dekoriert
natürlich seht ihr hier immer nur ein
Ausschnitt ich habe auch gearbeitet aber
das war heute eher leichte Arbeit also
PC Arbeit mit ein paar E-Mails
beantwortet kurz gehabt und dadurch dass
die Zeitumstellung noch nicht
eingetreten ist haben wir eigentlich
relativ früh Fastenbrechen gehabt zu
essen gab es dann die türkische
Linsensuppe Hähnchen und Reis und
außerdem auch noch ein Salat ich bin
immer am struggle ob ich mir abends noch
einen Kaffee gönnen soll aber diesmal
habe ich gedacht no risk no fun